gentlemen it's time to talk about
smallpox oh god do you read Allah I said
dark I had to ask you what the divisions
disease was before my life I completely
forgot i'm pretty sure that's what it is
i think its mother is some variation or
like I know they made some weird disease
i'm pretty sure it's kind of what
happened and they engineered something
yes what happened right by friday
disease yes greed probably some acronym
for it h1z1 mhm one that's a video game
that's a real h1n1 and that's a bird flu
right yes rice wine for blue Oh Burt I
don't know I get my flus makes yes
proposed the one of like murder you yeah
I explained food it's pretty it's not
that bad just a doable that flew right
yeah it's Lyman yeah it was more like
hedge I was like I felt like I was off
my face you read today's no but I wasn't
like getting sick running which is like
woo two days off work it's great i
called up NHS Direct which is like the
UK's like when you're sick you call them
thing they're like stay at home like
what like should I go to the hospital
they're like no I'm going hospital cuz
you'll infect everyone there stay down
it gets really bad let us know alright
so it's not a home played video games
for 24 hours mark your house and like
all right there's a guy in a house that
has if anything happens we know it's cuz
of that guy I got you just draw like it
like a pig snout on your front and then
he'd done anyway let's talk about the
division sweet came out last week yeah I
wasn't here no y'all made a bunch of
videos about it great job thanks that
game looks okay yeah depending on which
version you're it's it's actually pretty
amazing if you if you've looked at the
three versions like Xbox one is probably
by like easily by far the worse than the
socket on that Rob rabbit hole I can see
the YouTube thumbs downs just commenting
already alright so I want to talk to you
bout a bunch of stuff obviously we
talked about it on for a lot last week
but there's two kind of things I want to
talk about will talk about the pvp
soften a little bit but first of all I
want to float this idea where we bunch
of people who work here in the office
who have been plagued destiny for ever
since it came out every expansion pack
we go back in and we sort of talked
about it and we posed a lot of like is X
game better than Destiny's stuff all the
time and it gets really trite and
whatnot but I genuinely want to ask a
question
about if the division has sort of like
in its launch and in the type of
gameplay it has if it's like learned
from sore some of Destiny's shortcomings
because this is a game that i've been
playing only for about two days i wasn't
really into the Alpha very much but I'm
really enjoying this game the game I
think maybe the difficulty balance for
the Alpha was a set a little bit too
easy or something and I wasn't finding a
challenging but whatever reason I'm
really enjoying this game solo in a way
I never plays destiny so I want to pose
this to you guys you play a lot of
Destiny right yeah like nowhere you
obviously have a lot of dusting as well
so have you had this experience at all
that like you were enjoying this game
more or less or it's it's providing you
more of a I don't know an interesting
palette of world to play in and does
that even matter to you so if we're
gonna compare it to like destiny and my
experience like vice versa or whatever
once you hit the endgame it's very
different from early right early to
middle because i was playing early to
middle with rob and or solo and it was
fun because you know you're doing story
you're doing campaign and that stuff's
better than what launched destiny was
but when you hit end game and you start
having the you know grind out the dark
zone or do really hard missions that you
can't do solo i really miss like all my
destiny friends i'm playing on xbox one
right now I you know I don't know as
many people on xbox one I did that
because I know that the dlc is coming
out sooner and so it would be better for
content for us and I don't want a level
again on ps4 so that cross play stuff
might actually be good however uh just
getting to the end game which is like
man I really this sucks playing solo
like I don't want to do this any like
really anymore it's more motivating when
you're playing with a groove even if
it's not your friends necessarily to you
know you communicate you're like okay
it's such a huge thing because that's
what the skills are for you know like
I'm going to use my ultimate now or like
I'm gonna put pulse up or all right
let's use the marker button 5 is going
to count down five seconds alright we're
going to hit that target all to save
time you know like there's that
communication when you're playing kind
of by yourself it's like yeah and the
matchmaking yeah it's albeit it's good
because you can match me with other
people but you don't get that same
camaraderie you don't get the
communication and then just like falls
apart and for me that experience at
least end game isn't as fun i guess but
then again i had a group and destiny
knows I might not have if i was playing
by myself and destiny who knows i went
to fell off to that's like that's
literally the reason why i was something
it was because I just didn't find it fun
as a single fair game and I'm not lay
down much of the Division I you know
I've heard that it gets more challenging
and that you really want to squat up
later on but from what I've been playing
so far I've been like doing hard
missions and really enjoying it and
let's speak a little bit about the world
because I feel like that's another
aspect that I wasn't so much into a
destiny that obviously the story got
stripped out of it we realized you know
six months later that it had been
completely pulled out and they basically
like rejigged the game together and
that's when it felt so you know one
cohesive or whatever and the division
the story you can sort of take or leave
at they feel but like the world itself
the detail in the world the world
they've built all those little like
flashback things you can sort of dive
into it feels like there's a lot there
to explore have you been enjoying that
home like yeah that's the manger offer
me there maybe it's just because you
know it doesn't need sci-fi it's not
something I can relate to immediately
but like I know like Pete no Lex are
both from around New York as well right
and I was playing with Jake and Justin
last week and I pulled up the map and I
was like where are we right now I was
like oh we round like thirty fourth and
ninth I was like I lived like three
blocks from here obviously it's not a
one-to-one scale and it's not gonna look
the same but it's still really cool
because it did feel like New York and
then you go through the village and the
Christmas lights are still up and
they're all these like little stories
you see in the world that there's it's
there's not a lot of exposition with
those ones but it's still there for you
to find if you're looking for it and
that goes a long way to help me in most
games you know like The Witcher does a
great job of it you know the Elder
Scrolls games do a good job of that but
that's what's really pushing me forward
here and it I really really just I love
how the tone of it and just how it feels
like really lonely the city at the same
time but but at the same time you're
playing with other people and you're
kind of just going through these
alleyways like again not necessarily
that the same is what I've experienced
but it's a really alluring on just that
like environmental like tonal sense and
i'm really enjoying that aspect for sure
yeah i've done a lot of like wandering
off the beaten path recently or I just
said I just pick a part on the map and
kind of go over there and see what I run
into and I mean most of the side quests
they're pretty repetitive it's a lot
like this all the same yeah hostages why
not but there's still something about it
I don't know just like wandering around
and seeing like life just kind of
happening that you wouldn't have noticed
you me you might not have ever seen you
might not
I've ever gone over there and that I'm
really enjoying again maybe I just
haven't played enough of it you're not
getting tired of this a little snowy the
same though consecutive snow it's just
this like all the bit like yeah some of
the buildings are different but just in
terms of like running around the world
everything kind of looks similar other
than the day/night cycle which kind of
like tricks you a little bit in terms of
like what you see but I'm kind of over
the division world as it is what do you
think about the the upgrade loop that
they've put in because in a way it's
cotton well I guess it's not similar in
that way to destiny but destiny had a
sort of hob little area that you go back
to a large and obviously in the division
that takes places you also your upgrade
tree I guess how have you been enjoying
that aspect of like upgrading that the
very is that basically the crux of the
game as you're playing is upgrading your
your base and clearing out all those
missions I mean upgrading the base is
definitely important in the long run
because unlocking certain buildings will
give you a lot of good talents a lot of
good perks especially the
thousand-dollar one because that one
gives you your ultimate skill which is
like really clutch it I mean it's cool
to see how the headquarters change
changes as well when you kind of upgrade
it all the way I wouldn't say it's what
the endgame is that's just part of the
endgame the real endgame is just min
maxing your gear and that's really it's
like a loop it's like a loot chase
really it's more almost like Diablo than
anything else like it there's so many
kind of similar mechanics like you're
just farming for loot you're trying to
upgrade your losses your absolute like
you're trying to yelling the dice for
loot in that sort of wire ad kinda way
yeah but like destiny like you had the
raid right and the raid was kind of like
the endgame thing that you did to try to
acquire that loot there isn't I mean
there's number of the division there
like you still do dark zone and kind of
get that stuff but there isn't like
really that tier of gameplay yet yeah
yet uh that you do that you're like okay
this is the thing I am striving and
getting all my gear for to then do
something harder to get the best gear in
the game right now it's just you're
trying to make the best game gear in the
game one was our hope that it drops
which is like weird don't you get
someone later in the division that kind
of functions like a kadala the
Enchantress in Diablo yeah so she there
you get a recalibrating station in
in the headquarters after you upgrade a
tech ling and that lets you kind of roll
stats on your gear some like really min
max cater to the build you're going to
make you can make like a full support
build and have like nothing but
electronics or you can try to go super
tanky and go all stamina and that
thought was stationed games when the
sockets you can get that earlier it's
just like kind of not worth it to like
later to it later parts of the game
because you don't really need two min
max as much and so later in the game
like I feel at least i would say spend
more time playing the game than doing
that stuff because you're gonna replace
that stuff you know I mean it's
therefore when you hit or get close to
30 and you're like okay this backpacks
really good but this stat really sucks
but I could change that one thing and
you're like okay I'm gonna change that
one thing so that's kind of those are
the RPG ish type mechanics and I find
that cool that's like the coolest thing
for me but to do all that stuff you need
to have like credits and materials yeah
that's the stuff yet the great way to
know add the pork 67 says Greenwich
isn't in the game Mike oh it's not
apparently that's not where the
Christmas lights are all right but this
Christmas light somewhere else there you
go yeah a game that I says I'm loving
the story NPCs boat main friendlies and
major enemies seem like real people this
is the weirdest thing about this cake is
that they kind of do seem like real
people and I feel like this like
government [ __ ] who's literally
murdering people for looting it's like
here like I'm kind of like I think I was
more critical that when I played the
ALPHAN I was like oh this game sounds
realistic I was like I would hope when I
see the words Tom goddamn Clancy put on
a game like somebody who loves like
Rainbow six in Ghost Recon and even
advanced warfighter like having a little
realism but now I don't really care but
it is funny that you're like your iron
is making good point you find somebody
who's like losing a dead body mm-hmm
right so then you didn't see them kill
that person yeah and you go up there and
you [ __ ] ice them and then you lose
their bodies there's like there's no
more simplicity there rioters ok nanny
risers the vision agents to do rotor
these people out there bad people these
cleaners these riders these bikers we
gotta get rid of them they got goodly
hey look the Rikers are like ex-cons
right yeah that's you and then there's
dudes were growing over [ __ ]
flamethrowers like they need to go but
just like poor people and hoodies I keep
murdering what I think are just lower
class New York
like us at this gay like this cleaning
out the lower east side basically yeah
which isn't hey man do games they see
you they point the gun what are you
gonna do you're gonna let them shoot you
know right well also another weird
disconnect is when you rescue hostages
you unlock the door and you go in yeah
and then you find out like three
shotguns in the room like are you really
hostages at that point you couldn't
organize some shampoo or aura when you
give energy bar or a soda to a civilian
in need and they're like oh here have a
pistol like so you didn't need this
pistol to survive this post-apocalyptic
Little you just need a soda oh my
favorite part is don't even give it to
you to just drop it on the ground there
you go you gotta pick that up yeah pick
that up as a pistol crazy so is the only
difference between civilians and the bad
guys in this game is that they have
their hoods down cuz everyones got at
least like a park on uh well the
cleaners have like masks and stuff right
and well yeah a regular gen-pop 99%
hoodlums yeah i guess that's regular
people they have some type of headgear
yeah that's fair this is just some kids
slipped on hoodie she's gonna get iced
cuz it's cold and he's like smallpox
[ __ ] Peter games Greg Reiner
Isaac Jonathan have smallpox yura you
don't smallpox no I won't get it but
yeah I don't want to tell me what's not
much do you want your site so uh we were
talking in a some sort of history class
way back in the day and my teachers this
reason the world banded together to get
rid of this and then apparently it would
just if you were lying in a bed your
skin would become so covered in like pus
and boils that it would like mesh with
the sheets so when you roll over it'll
just like tear off mmm so that's why
smallpox was such a huge deal like you
did not want it so don't go out and
black friday don't stay away from New
York just yeah just err on the side of
caution things always myself might do
some viral marketing campaign which
might go wrong next year throw some big
sky
hi guys